let's talk about the one everyone's
talking about Tony Ferguson Patty
pamlett so when this first got announced
close friend of my texting goes it's not
announced yet but I think they're doing
Ferguson versus Patty pimlin and I go
finally finally Tony gets a winnable
fight person goes I agree he can win
this one I thought that was kind of the
general census not that it's an easy
fight I know he's lost six in a row but
just look at that murderous Roe my
question for you guys out there who are
so so against this fight with Tony
Ferguson Peg pimlet what aspect of mixed
martial arts is Patty pimlet better at
than Tony Ferguson striking no grappling
right Patty's biggest asset you think
he's a better submission artist than
Tony Ferguson wrestling no way now if
this is three years ago Tony mops the
floor with Patty at this point but to
say that Patty pimlets more dangerous
than Tony Ferguson is insane to me